take now americans are still buying up a
storm even with the fastest inflation in
decades the latest government data
showed that the value of retail
purchases increased 1.7 in october that
is the biggest gain since march and it
represents a pickup from the eight
tenths of one percent increase seen the
previous month elevated savings and
rising wages for many households are
supporting the spending
how much should we read into this data
point and what does it signal for the
holiday shopping season let's ask angie
solonki she is national director of
retail sales for colliers angie always
great to speak with you on quick take
when it comes to this latest retail
sales report what kind of story do you
think the numbers tell us
well it's really interesting as you just
share inflation definitely is playing a
role but i would say that it's playing a
role in certain segments for example we
already know gas is going up but we're
also seeing a continued increase in
grocery spend so inflation has played a
role in that point where i think it's
representing around 64
of uh the the numbers hence the
complementary growth in that sector and
some of the beneficiaries from that are
going to be walmart because people are
being somewhat cautious as they look at
the upcoming holidays where they do want
to spend uh quite a bit of money as you
just shared buying just stuff and gifts
um purely because they can with the
elevated savings but also because people
have been vaccinated some have received
their booster shots and so they're
really looking to enjoy and have a good
time this holiday season
so
yeah when you look at the walmart
conversation it's very interesting that
i think what we're going to see is a
little bit of that inflation trickling
in but closer to maybe q2 of 2022.
that's really interesting given that
walmart shares today are down almost 3
percent because uh the company signaled
this bracing for more pressure from all
the
contagion caused uh snafus when it comes
to transportation and shipping logistics
and the costs overall are rising faster
than its prices because as a low-cost
retailer walmart only has so much room
to increase prices before it's it's
customer-based box at that
i want to dig in a little bit more on
that inflation figure because you said
uh that we're looking at about
two-thirds of the
increase that we saw in retail sales
attributed to inflation
how are retailers thinking about that
proportion do they see that uh staying
stable over the next say three months
six months or do they see inflation uh
representing a bigger chunk of their
sales in coming months
i would say scarlett what will be really
interesting is of course the holiday
season is probably the most important
season for retailers that's where you're
going to see the majority of the
holidays spend or consumers spend and so
what we've seen is with a lot of the
retailers who are well prepared due to
supply chain issues have stocked their
stores and stocked their shelves with
merchandise that they can sell at full
price with that that's going to help
with margins and hopefully offset some
of the concerns around inflation
therefore we're really forecasting a
pretty healthy 2022 year end
but it's going to be interesting to see
what happens
as we move into q1 and q2 of next year
i wonder though how consumers feel
because there's this narrative that
even though inflation is picking up and
consumer sentiment is souring because of
that pickup in inflation americans are
actually in decent financial shape they
have elevated savings they are making
more in wages overall
do retailers see that and it's a matter
of convincing people to spend even
though prices are higher or are they
adjusting for people's sentiment that
seems to signal they're very weary
they're concerned that things are going
the wrong direction
yeah not as of yet so we're still seeing
a very optimistic outlook from consumers
spend and therefore people are still
looking at the holidays as another way
to start sharing buying gifts we
actually saw you know most consumers
start their holiday shopping spree
as early as september of course in
october a lot of it had to do with
supply chain concerns i mean there's
been several interesting tick tock
messages out there from various um
consumers and patrons and also shop
owners and so you know kind of
challenging the supply chain but people
are still quite optimistic they i think
they're really tired of hearing about
you know the challenges from last year
they're looking forward to really
celebrating 2021 so we actually saw an
increase for example in apparel um and
you know we're thinking to ourselves wow
we went from athleisure wear to now you
know people buying more winter wear
buying you know shoes and dresses and
things that are going to be fun and
exciting for your end and it was roughly
around let's say a 23 increase in
apparel sales for the month of october
so when you start to see these numbers
you start to see people are are spending
now
will it start to rain in i think so but
i don't think it's going to occur this
year
interesting it just speaks to the the
power of retail therapy um on our
national psyche what product areas do
you see as being the most negatively
affected by all the inventory issues
that we do face at the end of this year
during the holiday shopping season the
the thick of the holiday shopping season
and into
2022 sure you know what was really
fascinating to me as a kind of secret
shopper myself is you know as i started
to kind of explore the different stores
and different categories what i found
very interesting to me was there were
definitely areas within like in the
grocery segment uh where they were
completely out of certain items and so i
was surprised by that um you know for
example just even water i was i thought
for you know at least we would have you
know no issues as it relates to water
but i saw a kind of a decline in that in
that area also some of the staple goods
um which was really surprising to me and
it just was again had to do with supply
chain just the merchandise didn't get
off the ship and into the stores fast
enough the other areas that we're also
seeing which i find very interesting is
that when you go into a store now yes it
is fully merchandise in stock but you
might start to see
a um you know less number of skus so not
as many as you know call it 100 skus in
a store it might be 50 skus in a store
but it's somewhat i wouldn't say it's an
illusion um but when you're going into a
store it still feels full and full of
merchandise but maybe the variety is
going to be less
right and you're seeing that balance
yeah when you refer to sku of course
we're talking about basically the the
selection of products that are available
out there um
i want to get from you a sense of what
the shortage of workers means for the
different retailers that are out there
obviously they've been trying to hire
for months now and it just becomes that
much more dire during the holiday
shopping season do you see them adapting
to
technological solutions and is that a
temporary fix or permanent fix
no definitely innovation uh as it
relates to technology in stores
is uh is in the forefront many retailers
have figured out how to
improve the overall um issue regarding
labor and uh whereby they put in if you
probably have noticed in many of the
larger format stores um you know the
contactless kind of the
point of sale so basically you're not
going through
a standard cashier you're basically
checking yourself out um and so they're
making they're adding more and more of
those uh checkout stations for for
consumers people are having a lot of fun
doing it it just kind of brings you back
uh and playing those kind of childhood
games of a grocery store
but that's where they're handling kind
of this labor uh concern and issue so
you have less people staffed at the
cashiers because you have more um you
know
cashier list stations got it final
question for you
angie i wanted to ask you about the
circular economy because you've been
writing about that and how um stores or
retailers that offer second-hand goods
or pre-owned items are in a position to
benefit right now because of the
inventory shortage the inventory crunch
but not just temporarily going forward
this is something that american
consumers have really started to to
adapt to and to really get enthusiastic
about
you know scarlett what's really
fascinating to me is as i you know try
to kind of integrate with the various
generations to see how they are spending
you know when you look at the
millennials and the generations um you
know beyond um it's it's very
i would say in their dna as it relates
to how they're spending uh their money
and where they're spending their money
it's important to them that they spend
in a way that also gives back so what i
mean by that um you're starting to see
these these consumers look at okay i can
have the latest or i can have a vintage
you know uh purse belt jacket pair of
shoes but have you um through this
collet circular or the second hand uh
consignment and so they're taking
something that they want to enjoy for a
period of time but they're also okay
giving it up and giving it back to the
next person versus trying to hold on to
it and just stockpile it in their closet
so i think you know we're going to
continue to see that that is definitely
not a trend um i don't remember what the
stat is but there's a pretty significant
double digit uh percentage of people
buying that segment right but they're
they're also i would say the people that
are um selling the second-hand items or
the consignment items are also faced
with supply issues as well yeah but
those supply issues are fairly minimal
compared to the uh the ones that other
retailers face angie thank you so much
for your time angie solonki is director
of retail sales for colliers based in
san francisco